an official release day for the sequel
to spider-man into the spider-verse has
dropped spinning fans into a web of
excitement and there's a lot to know
about where the spider verse could be
headed so let's talk about it right now
on the catch up the oscar-winning into
the spider verse delighted critics and
fans when it was released almost a year
ago and has a certified fresh' tomato
meter score of 97% and an audience score
of 93 percent so it's no surprise that
much more content from the spider verse
it's coming our way and thanks to the
film's official Twitter page we can now
mark April 8th 2022 on our calendars as
a day we will get to see spider ham
again and miles morales and all the
other Spidey's too obviously but come on
spider ham was a real MVP there don't
worry people it's a hundred percent beef
so to know where the spider verse will
go next let's start by looking at the
post-credits scene from the first movie
that's when we met Miguel O'Hara better
known to fans of the comics a spider-man
2099 he's from a version of New York
called away by York and his origin story
involves working at alchemax which was
the bad guy company from into the
spider-verse
in the scene he's voiced by none other
than Oscar Isaac and after deciding to
do some multiverse traveling for himself
he lands in the 1967 animated spider-man
series and let's just hope he'll finally
get to find out who actually pointed
first dare you point at me who you were
pointing first so hopefully we'll get to
see spider-man 2099 playing a major role
in the sequel and producer writer Phil
Lord just confirmed on Twitter that an
animated version of Japanese spider-man
has been designed for the sequel as well
so if you don't know much about Japanese
spider-man he originally premiered in
1978 and rather than Peter Parker or
Miles Morales his alter ego was a
motorcycle racer named Takuya Yamashiro
and it brought plenty of cheesy
seventies action
as far as the rest of the spider-verse
goes the sequel is really just the
beginning because spider-gwen voiced by
Hailee Steinfeld in the first one is
reportedly getting her own female lead
spin-off film birds of prey style Sony
chief Amy Pascal confirmed to Variety
last December that Gwen will team up
with both Cindy moon aka silk and
Jessica drew Marvel's original Spider
Woman and that was pretty much the last
we've heard about this film but based on
further developments in a spider verse
it could also be shifting to a TV series
and of course we'll keep you all posted
on that just as long as you hit that
subscribe button shameless plug and
let's not forget about the other spider
people who joined miles in the first
film with writers Phil Lord and Chris
Miller inking a huge deal with Sony TV
earlier this year to make a bunch of
shows you've got to think spider noir
penny Parker or even spider-ham will be
getting their own series I truly feel
like there's a little something for
everyone here except maybe Tobey Maguire
fans
but let's remember that the spider-verse
is huge
on top of all that animated fun the live
actual world of Spidey is in full swing
ahead as well with a Morbius movie venom
sequel and a third Tom Hollands
spider-man film all coming in the next
couple years and of course that's a
whole other episode of the catch up so
did you subscribe yet you ready yeah
you're gonna love this all right it's
time for us to kick it over to you now
are you excited for what's to come in
the animated spider-verse
who's your favorite version of
spider-man and should post Malone make
the single for the sequel really asking
the hard-hitting questions here let us
know all your thoughts in the comment
section and for more on all things
spider-man head on over to Ryan tomatoes
calm and good news our first book rotten
movies that we love is out right now it
celebrates 101 movies that are coming in
green but definitely worth checking out
anyway as always thank you for watching
the catch up if you liked this episode
and you want to see more we know you do
subscribe and click that Bell icon I'm
nice press and I'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
you